طاردتها الصحافه لسنوات تعرضت شخصيتها
لهجوم بلا هواده لكنها عززت مكانتها في
رحله صعبه وطريق طويله كامله الملكه
القرينه البريطانيه هي الاكثر تاثيرا لعام
2023 وذلك من بين قائمه 50 امراه وضعتها
صحيفه
في مجالات عده كالرياضه والبيئه والسياسه
وغيرها تستضيف كاميرا يوم الاربعاء حفل
استقبال لنساء العالم في قصر باكيهام
الملكي لها بصمتها الخاصه في قضايا العنف
ضد المراه والاغتصاب كذلك على صعيد محو
الاميه والتوعيه بمرض هشاشه العظام
[موسيقى]
بالحب والصبر عاشت الملكه القرينه الملك
بطانيه تشارلز الثالث سيدت قصر بوكينغهام
الجديده كامله
وصلت في النهايه الى القبول من الناس ومن
الملك الراحله اليزابيث التي باركت وصولها
الوشيك الى لقب الملكه القرين وذلك قبيله
وفاتها باشهر كانت الملكه القرينه حبا
قديما لتشارلز وهي تعرضت لاقصى حمله علنيه
ضدها فهي المتهمه الاولى والاخيره بالنسبه
لكثيرين ومنذ سنوات لانها قضت على الحياه
الزوجيه التشارلز وديانا كامله دخلت القصر
بعد ديانه في عام 2005 راقبت الصحافه
مظهرها وشخصيتها الخجوله العائله المالكه
لم تفضلها كزوجه لملك المستقبل لكن
العلاقه انتصرت في النهايه تمضي الايام
وهي تجتاز العواصف التي لحقت بها بعد
زواجها من ولي العهد لتعزز مكانتها
بالاسره الحاكمه
كما ستجلس الى جانب الملك تشارلز يوم
تتويجه في السادس من مايو المقبل
[موسيقى]
نورنا في الاستوديو لاول مره مديره مكتب
العربيه في لندن الاعلاميه الجميله ريما
مكتبي نشكرك على تواجدك معنا في الاستوديو
اليوم صباح الخير يسعد هالصباح يا ريما
ومنورتينا في صباح العربيه انا بحضركن من
سنوات هذا من برامج المفضله
التي ضل شبح ديانا يرافقها لسنوات يعني
قطعت مشوارا طويلا الى مكانتها ملكه قرينه
واليوم المراه الاكثر تاثيره في العالم
بحسب الانتبانت كيف اثرت ريما كاميرا اولا
ما بدي ازعلكم كتير يعني هيدا العنوان
كتير حلو بس على الارجح شبكه او شبكه
علاقات عامه هي اللي دفعت باتجاه هذا
التايتل هذا اللقب ممكن مبرر اللي عم
بتقوليه لانه تحضير للتنصيب هناك عمل على
صوره كاملا من عشيقه الى ملكه
هيدا احدى العناوين بصحف البريطانيه فعاده
شركات البي ار او علاقات العامه بتيجي
مثلا نادين خماش بتقلها انا بدي حسن صورتي
اذا كان
او سهام
بتوظفيهم وممكن يعملوا هذا اليوم الحدث هو
بمناسبه يوم المراه العالمي مستضيفته
الملكه
سميت عده نساء من حول العالم لاكثر تاثيرا
بس كمان في حفل للملكي ممكن يكون
بسيااق حمله علاقات عامه لا شك انك مره
كثير قويه انها تنتقل من مركز عشيقه في
عائله ملكيه تقليديه الى زوجي وبعائله ما
فيها طلاق لانه الطلاق محرم
بالديانه المسيحيه
الصراحه
كل الوقت دائما في تعليقات نازله في كامله
كل الوقت بس اليوم اذا احنا بدنا نحكي على
كلمه التاثير الاكثر تاثيرا هل لك تاثير
على ملك دوله عظمى وهو الملك تشارلز اليوم
لها تاثير على الملك اكيد لكن لا تاثير
لها على الشعب البريطاني بشكل كبير حتى
شعبيه الملك تشارلز كتير عانه عبر السنوات
وصارت احسن مع الوقت لكن ليست فئه وجهها
وهي يمكن احيانا صورتها تتاثر بتعليق هنا
او تعليق هناك والامير هاري رجع سماها
زوجه الاب الشريره فبالتالي ما ساعد فكل
هذا جزء من ايضا لحد منتبعات كتاب الامير
هاري تحضير لحفر التنصيب اللي راح يكون
النا تغطيه كبيره فيها بين سته وثمانيه
مايو
فالى تاثير على الملك تشارلز هيدي امراه
كان بحبها ما خلوه يتزوجها تزوج ديانا
لانه عندها اللقب
والحب
فالحب طغى ورجع اتجوزها يعني رجع صار معها
بالاخر شبح ديانا راح يضل يلحقها فعلا طيب
ريما كل الانشطتها الملكيه وواجباتها
الملكيه اللي زادت في السنوات الاخيره
طريقه استجابتها للاساءات الشخصيه كما قلت
خصوصا من الامير هاري بوصفها زوجه الاب
الشريره الم يزد من تنامي شعبيتها الم
يكسبها شعبيه عم تحاول ولا شك انه هناك
تعاطف مع كاميلا يعني هي من الشعب
البريطاني حاولت كتير انها تلعب هيدا
الدور بعدين اذا بتلاحظوا هي السيده ما
كتير بتشتغل بوجهها مش عامله بوتوكس مش
عامله عمليات تجميل فانا استغربت من عمرها
يعني توقعت تكون اكبر منعيه توقعت اكبر من
هيك عمرها 75
اصيبت بكورونا من فتره لكل الي عليها لانه
زوجه الملك فمع الوقت ناس تقبلتها ولكن
للاسف بكل مناسبه كبيره شبح
الاجتماعيه وعندي كمان شيء قلك اياه بحفله
تنصيب للمره الاولى تاجا راح يكون تاج
مستعار مش تاج جديد
لانه في ازمه ماليه وهذه الحفلات من اموال
دافعيه ضرائب وبالتالي انا هي بتقول انا
بستعمل تاج مستعمل من قبل لملكه قديمه
وراح يعدلوا شوي بالاحجار الكريمه ما راح
تكلف الناس الثمن تاج جديد معنا ريما
مكتبي في الاستوديو شكرا جزيلا شكرا اكيد
منحكي للمشاهدين وانتظروا تغطيه قناه
العربيه ريما راح تكوني على راس هذه
التغطيه وبتذكرينا كمان بوقت وفاه كوين
اليزابيث شكرا للاستضافه حلو انه اطلع مع
صديقاتي على الشاشه تسلمي لريما شكرا
نورتينا شكرا